so let's start by talking about Osama
bin Laden whose plays the title role in
your book which is called the killing of
Osama bin Laden you challenged virtually
every detail of the story both the
official narrative and the media reports
can you start by summarizing sort of
briefly what you what you found in this
piece well basically the the 1:1 reality
is the President did authorize the
execution if you will of a sama bin
Laden the seals did carry it out and
that's a fact and that's absolutely
correct and it was done in a bottle bot
which was a resort town about 50 or 60
miles up up up hill from from Islamabad
the capital and it's a place that in the
summer in Islamabad if you've been there
in summers it gets to 120 and so it's a
it's I call it the Martha's Vineyard of
Islamabad it's a package that were they
rich and the the generals and the senior
bureaucrats go and they have summer
houses it's sort of an upscale area that
all happened after that it's sort of
what I describe as a Lewis Carroll story
because the White House said this was
all done he was he'd gone there he'd
last time we heard about bin Laden we
were looking for him in the mountains
the Tora Bora area between Pakistan and
Afghanistan the Hindu Kush mountains
sort of a wild man no-man's land we were
looking for him we couldn't find him
this is late Oh 102 we went on a bomb an
attack Iraq and and and moved away we're
still in this war that 15 years now Bob
and you know how are we doing in that
war but no no that's another question
and so I'll give it another 15 years oh
my god yes there's no end it seems I win
because we're doing the same policy my
argument basically in the book in the
essays in the book most of them are
written for the London Review of Books
all of them were and not that well-known
here is argument that is that didn't
that Osama bin you know that that the
president you know States the Baraka
Barack
followed the Cheney Bush policy much too
much much more than we really want to
know anyway the story is that the White
House story is that oh my god we had
wonderful couriers we had people in the
basement of the CIA were tracking
couriers and bin Laden once he left Tora
Bora why he was active he was and he was
the energetic runner and he was sending
messages and directing traffic for al
Qaeda
I guess worldwide that's sort of the
implication never quite said that and
then the courier's with amazing skill
and with the use of torture
waterboarding if anybody seen the movie
that was generated out of this zero dark
thirty I think it's called I just yet it
begins with a torture enhanced
interrogation waterboarding and we got
the evidence we wanted we got bin Laden
and then we didn't tell the Pakistanis
and we went in by ourselves two choppers
could evade the radar of Pakistan and
went in and did the mission kill the guy
and the guy in the initial story he had
an ak-47 when they confronted him bin
Laden and in order to protect themselves
the seals had to shoot him there in in
in a in a room in on a compound there
and then we we fled out and we had a
copper we had a chopper that was a blew
up it was an accident a crash-landed and
since the Blackhawks the the chopper
which the to the 22222 squaws actually
forced was of six says this Navy SEALs
even though they haven't been on water
in years they still move in groups of
six which that's how many fit into a
dinghy sort of a nice touch because the
seals have gone crazy with the fact that
they don't go they go inland they're not
going into the water anymore
and many of them leave because that's
just not what they were trained to do
not just run on the ground and kill
people but anyway the seals went in and
and had to kill him I took that took the
body out and flew back meanwhile a
rescue chopper came in which was a two
inch in a twin-engine a chopper I've
forgotten the name of it
it's a Kerry's 55 passengers it travels
about a hundred and ten maybe 130 miles
an hour
and most and with the they took that out
along with the Blackhawk because they
didn't have enough room in the one
Blackhawk and they flew out that way
without being detected by the radar
that's the story and the American press
went gung-ho for it it was a great night
when the president announced we've got
him that was the words you know
basically he's he was killed and the war
on terror is over and Americans marks in
the streets and I celebrated it too was
very happy to see him dead although I
knew this guy had been out of business
for ten years this isn't going to end
the war but in the next week or so the
American press they as to what happens
when you get a story like this the White
House controlled the narrative they're
begging for briefings everybody wants an
exclusive and they're dealing out facts
they had a recant after a little while
that he didn't have an ak-47 then they
went to he had to woman with weapons
protecting him and then they had to back
off that and there was a firefight a
huge firefight a lot of people were shot
up and killed they have a really backed
off that but that's sort of diminished
and if you remember his wives and
children were were taken away and we're
gonna we're gonna interrogate them that
never happened they were flown out by
the Pakistani intelligence service a few
a month or so later back to Saudi Arabia
all these stories sort of this
disintegrated over the next couple of
weeks but nobody paid attention we were
still the press will still tell us more
and what I remember in my favorite story
was the one about one of the seals have
brought a dog in on the mission and they
described how the president met the dog
and and one of the stories was that when
the chopper crashed they had to blow it
up and you know big explosion and if
people came neighbors came in this very
sort of elegant area of Pakistan a
resort area if people came to wonder
what's going on the dog was put outside
to tell him you know to stay away and I
remember thinking oh my god we've got a
dog that barks in Urdu which is the
local nature a bird knew barking dog so
there was no story that wouldn't go
there fire department in this area which
is very skilled the police department
which is very skilled did not show up at
all even though the time of the mission
which was supposed to be 20 minutes
ended up being 40 because the
the seals had a fly in a rescue chopper
that was also parked in Pakistan but
again without the I the Pakistani
knowledge and so it's such a bad story
let me just tell you a few things that
one of my my one of my complaints
chronically you know when I speak to
journalism schools and I speak actually
more in Europe on investigative
journalism than here these days but but
still the annual meetings of the IRA
investigative reporting group I speak to
a lot of schools now the first thing I
always say is you have to read before
your right
you've got to read and so one of the
things you need to do is take a look at
the radar system that Pakistan had and
I'll just take a second to tell you what
the rate how it began
we know that bin Laden worked for us in
in the in the early 80s when we decided
Jimmy Carter and Brzezinski decided
we're going to drive the Russians we're
gonna have a proxy war with the Russians
in Afghanistan and Jordan for
schadenfreude the Russians were stuck as
we thought we had been in Vietnam and we
were gonna go and we use a bin Laden and
other fundamentalists to help fight a
war and win the war and we also brought
in we began paying a lot of money to the
Pakistani intelligence service which is
known as the ISI and now it's become one
of the great tough services of all time
the Pakistani ISI is like the Egyptian
military they have great investments
they own things they buy property in
Australia they're building a huge
housing and business complex in
Islamabad they're big they're tough
they're very skilled we all know that we
brought them in to help us fight the
Taliban and the other groups inside
Afghanistan helped us win the war
against the Russians and what happened
then is the Pakistan is very unwisely
the one thing that happened is when the
ISI got in when to go back as you know
there's a long enmity between India and
Pakistan to royal colonies of the Brits
that split up and when when the Russians
began to move in the Pakistan and the
Indians moved in they set up not only
they had an embassy but they set up
consulates when the ISI began to fight
on our side one of the things they did
when I'm telling you now was reported
and pressed
find that in news clips they invaded
some of the consulates and began killing
Pakistani diplomats and even hanging
some you know that kind of entity exists
well then in the early by eighty five or
so when they were active in all the anti
Indian and all er stuff for us inside
Afghanistan helping us beat the Russians
and drive him out at that point the
Indians had nuclear weapons and could
deliver them Pakistan had a reactor
going a place called Cohutta enriching
uranium but they weren't able to
weaponize yet so what did they what did
they do they said help us and so what
did we do we put up money over eight or
ten years to build a very sophisticated
3d audible which means you can't erase
it a signal a system I think Raytheon
was the main contractor when I looked at
it was over nine hundred million bucks
we built a great radar system for them
and between Islamabad and Delhi there's
one flight one or two flights a weeks
now and it's about an hour flight 350
miles or so and so my god all you had to
do is look up the kind of radar system
they had and you knew this story that
they the story the basic story that our
two Blackhawk helicopters could evade
radar was a ludicrous just ludicrous so
you start from there and I began looking
at all the different so what so what you
said well you said in your article and
in what just in the book let me just
sort of suggest some things is that it
wasn't brilliant intelligence that
discovered where bin Laden was but it
was a walk in it was a tip from a
Pakistani officer that we took that to
the Pakistanis and said now we know
where he is so either you cooperate or
else they did they cleared the decks for
the whole US operation we we moved into
Pakistan knowing that they were
basically standing down in and around
the compound and in the skies of
Pakistan
there was no firefight as the
administration said it was really just
one old guy who was not just shot once
or twice but as you say obliterated by
by the fire they even allowed us to set
up you report
command center in a nearby Pakistani
facility to guide the whole operation so
this was really a complete myth
essentially that was created by the
administration in order to protect
Pakistan I guess from the consequences
among other things um is that about
right or that's a perfect summary the
the the man that walked in I was a I I
can be less coy about him now because
the Pakistanis obviously know who he is
he was a Pakistani colonel had and not
in the is iben and military intelligence
army intelligence who was disaffected
and there was 25 million dollars on the
table we offered that much money for
information about Pakistan he did come
in 2010 and to show you how sort of
naive I am he I made a point of early in
the piece of writing that he went
directly to our station chief a very
competent guy named Jonathan bank who
and what I did in the article is I wrote
that Bank was there because Bank had
been mentioned earlier particularly in
the Urdu press because there been a flap
involving the CIA and we had to move him
out of the country early and it was so
his name was mentioned you know it's
against the law to write the name of a
covert operator it's a theoretical they
haven't really tried to push that law
but it is a law but even mentioned so I
mentioned him by name for the simple
reason that I thought the way you could
really go after me in this story there
was a long story it's ten thousand words
and was checked very carefully by the
land just as carefully as when I worked
for stuff for The New Yorker they in
fact they the London Review hired some
of my better New Yorker checkers who did
the checking and took weeks of this
stuff you know it costs a lot of money
to do this right which The New Yorker is
famous for doing in any case I thought
by leaving his name in there I knew I
was gonna jeopardize him because there
are many people in the government
immediately think because he's named he
was the source but he wasn't in any case
I thought the way I could really be hurt
on this story I knew there'd be attacks
by the White House is if John is they
somehow could convince John banks who
are bank who I knew had a reputation for
being honest to go public
three or four days after my story which
attracted enormous attention as we all
knew it would and go public and say walk
in her shy don't know what he's talking
about he said nothing and I thought the
press would appreciate the dog that
didn't bark is really important but they
didn't they were too busy chasing the
White House briefings that really pay
attention to the fact that who wasn't
talking about it the one guy that was
directly involved well and so let me
certainly you certainly had yeah well
the the other point is that of course
the underlying point here the most
critical point is when all of this was
being planned when we confronted the
Pakistanis we were enraged them for and
of course their answer to the whole
point was they they were gonna look the
other way we were gonna go take him out
we had to take the body out and we were
not gonna talk about it not for a week
or ten days and was all agreed the
president then would announce we had a
drone raid we do it all the time in the
Hindu Kush mountains on the Pakistani
and not on the pack on the Afghan side
making clear was on the Afghan side and
we hit a house a wooden house with a
Hellfire missile and we did of
after-action look we found a long tall
guy there I've been Laden 64 or
something like that and we did DNA and
my god we got him and that would have
been just as good but that night and I
remember this vividly because it was a
Sunday night here in Washington and by
7:30 8:00 there were reports all over
the media that the president has a
special announcement to make and by 10
o'clock there were stories that might do
it might have to do with bin Laden but
he didn't go public time almost three
hours after the first word and what was
going on was a fight because there was
pressure on him political pressure from
the political advisors not to wait the
seven or ten days they were very angry
and Robert Gates the Republican
Secretary of Defense whom gateshead if
you remember gates have been reappointed
or in allowed to stay by he'd been
appointed he replaced Rumsfeld by but by
George Bush and he was very close to the
Bush family Gates was and when Obama
came in he reappointed him but two and a
half years later there was tension
inside a Republican doing things and
Gates was very much against some of the
things that happened in the operation he
thought we should bomb the play
let it go and not jeopardize the seals
because if something had gone wrong and
they'd been captured they would be
accused of they were they had no
protection they were they were basically
committing a war crime in he was a
prisoner of wars at the point and they
executed a prisoner of war and they went
into a country with without any notice
for the authorities that's theoretically
what happened so anyway here's what the
issue was four gates basically an N and
for me as a journalist what's so
important about Pakistan why do we have
spend so much time cozying it up to the
generals who run it it's because they
control more than right now when I wrote
about it in the New Yorker in 2009 it
was more than a hundred nuclear weapons
and we worry about their weapons we
worry about their safety there's a huge
Muslim fundamental property mentalist
population in Pakistan and in fact the
reason that the Pakistanis had never
Indic said anything publicly about
having him since oh six is when they
walk in told us he came in well is I
found him in O six according to the walk
in which may or may not be correct it
could be earlier I think it might be but
in any case that's what they walk in
told us the Pakistanis kept them
secretly because the public would go
nuts they the public's that love bin
Laden many elements of the public fifty
percent forty percent of the country a
psalm as a hero and so as long as they
had bin Laden they could privately tell
the I Qaeda groups and the Taliban
groups in both Pakistan and Afghanistan
we got your guy pay more attention to us
keep us informed they had more control
that was her argument the second
argument they made explanation for
keeping him is the Saudis paid him a lot
of money the Saudi Arabia government you
know he's a Saudi he came from and they
he came from an elegant a very wealthy
family bin Laden family in Saudi Arabia
big construction family not royal family
but they were major constructionists an
in building building and very wealthy
and the assumption we make and I make is
that nobody wanted an American
interrogation team to talk to him so the
whole deal once the Pakistani leadership
general named Pasha who ran the ISA and
a general renamed kyani oh my god what
we did for them you want a new armored
car yeah
you want a helicopter yeah Kiani love
golf you want to go play golf with Jack
Nicholson Jack Nicklaus and in in Ohio
why we'll fix it up we did that stuff
for them because we wanted them to trust
us enough to let us know where the bombs
were and it was a cat-and-mouse game
going on of course we didn't tell him
what we planned and they didn't tell us
everything to the word in the
intelligence community our fear was that
some of the bombs that they were telling
us about you know where they were an egg
loser under the ground where some of the
bombs actually were hidden in the tall
grass along the runway out of account
they always kept a few there was this
not just natural suspicion so this is
what's on the table so that night when
the president decides to violate the
agreement he's really jeopardizing a
relationship that I will tell you until
today has not been fully resolved
there's still bitterness and among the
Pakistani leadership about being hung
out to dry well if they were if they
were holding captive and public enemy
number one and not only holding him
captive but protecting him and using him
to their advantage they they obviously
have a lot to answer for your story in
the book and in the London Review has
been disparaged by a lot of people but
there were also people like carla de
Gaulle and some other folks Steve call
NBC that confirmed details of what you
reported are you surprised though sigh
that there's been so little follow-up in
other words that so few journalists
since this piece first came out have
picked up one or another piece of it and
and tried to confirm or disprove what
you wrote are you can well you know are
you concerned or surprised by that when
I was at the New York Times for seven
eight nine years I was there sort of
hotshot lead investigative reporter I
want a lot of prizes you know writing
about Watergate writing about Vietnam
and the CIA in Chile and all that stuff
I Kissinger's wiretapping
and the domestic wire domestic spying by
the CIA that led to the church sure he's
a lot of wonderful stories and if
somebody at the Times that said there's
a great story that was published by the
LA Times he wants you to follow it I
would
B I don't follow other people's stories
I do my own it's a very [ __ ] business
so for the really good reporters the
good investigative reporters and the
times and the posts etc they don't want
to follow someone else's story it's just
a reality and here's the thing that
really got me was within a week of the
story there was a interview show with I
want to embarrass anybody but there was
a senior reporter for the Washington
policy reporter for The Washington Post
one of those reporters who doesn't like
following other stories and this
reporter was asked about my story and
the reporter said well actually she said
we all sort of knew right away this is
within five or six days of the
publication of my story we all knew that
the Pakistani military and intelligence
services had to know where he was it
didn't make sense that they did not that
part of the story doesn't work and but
yes so what what was being said
essentially was we had that we you know
that's tough that's how you get rid of a
story I used to work for the AP covered
in the Pentagon in the 60s on the job
training and learning how to hate the
Vietnam War and as the reporter for the
AP if anybody broke to a good story they
would call me and wake me up at 11:30 at
night sometimes the the New York desk or
the overseas desk can you match it and
the first thing I would do was call the
press secretary for Robert McNamara who
I concluded was a psychotic liar the
afterworld dealing with him I really did
I thought they just locked was lying
about everything and it didn't even know
how much he was lying
I see later sort of talked about you
know later Errol Errol a wonderful movie
by a great movie maker anyway I would
call up and say can I have your denial
so now your file is still he'd say the
Pentagon tonight today I'm telling you
it was that petty that's how [ __ ] we
are in the business but I was you know
it's funny you crossed the water this
book came out in London too at the same
time as it did here and I would I went
for a few days to London and did a
couple of big events in it like you know
at with in one case with an senior
editor of a of a major newspaper there
and we had a there were a lot of people
there and we talked about the bin Laden
story and I turned tables
after a few minutes I asked him I said
you guys though pack your clothes er you
know as I said it's a world colony you
guys go to India and Pakistan you have
much more ties you're much more
sophisticated about that part of the
world and we are we have all that water
between us and he said yes and I said so
what did you guys think he said I'm not
exaggerating he said well we had
meetings to be concluded right away was
it possible for the Pakistani or ISI
because you know how confident they are
not to know that we're he he was there
because among other things
obadah bot happens to be in the center
literally the center of not only the
secret base you mentioned about you know
you mentioned earlier a secret base in
which we worked with the Pakistani
intelligence service and our CIA on
covert ops also a base in which the
Pakistanis trained the guards for the
nuclear arsenal to reactors Pakistan now
has a plutonium reactor also in a ring
about it a major air base if you circle
draw a circle in the middle as a bada
bot he wasn't there by accident they
parked him in a place where they had
total coverage and also they made it
clear the pact you know it was clear in
the earlier reporting and you have to go
back to the first things that were said
he had no internet
he had no electronic communication he
was he was completely isolated in fact
arge our guys when we landed we were
walked into his prison by an ISI
official and if you remember in even in
the stories they told we had to blow two
steel doors if there were two steel
doors
why was he was a prisoner clearly a
prisoner of war a prisoner of what you
want not a prisoner of love but anyway
it's just the morgue I don't know there
have been he Co has been a lot of
criticism to write of the story not just
lack of follow-up but I cooked out a few
quotes I'm sure you heard them Mark
Bowden says it's fake moon landing
territory love story and Peter burger
called it a farrago of nonsense the
salon and political and Voxx wade in The
Washington Post talked about it being
quote even too kind even kind of crazy
said that Paul fire either media guy
so what's this all about why was there
so much not just failure to follow up
but but this kind of of nastiness of you
know accusing you of being a conspiracy
monger well there are a couple things
about what's that about well I mean I've
had this most of my career with all most
of my stories there's been enormous
amount of criticism you know when I did
the meal I story when I not so much
albergue rave we had a document there
but I did the albergue rape story yeah
but a lot of the stories if you look at
the original story I wrote about the
seat domestic CI spying in the New York
Times there was December late December
2000 1974 my god the Washington Post
three months was attacking me and saying
that wasn't right I was all you know
that that there weren't files the see I
wasn't keeping files on Americans etc
etc and all of that stuff eventually you
know people you know that's uh you tell
me you know I don't want to use I don't
want to describe what it's about I mean
I it's pretty obvious in some cases what
it is because you know I've been doing
this a long time and writing story said
often people that should have been
written by others much earlier so part
of it is that in the case of Mark Bowden
I like Mark Bowden evoke Black Hawk Down
he were good friends and and you heard
him in your book a couple of times well
I called him because one first you have
to know something in the CIA when you
have a walk in that's manna you protect
the walk in and so here you have in the
basement of the Intelligence Bureau
there you have a bunch of people working
on tracking couriers you want to figure
out where the courier's are and if you
pay attention to the Senate Intelligence
Committee which last year if you
remember I think early last year they
published a major report on terror and
as a torture if you remember that report
it was a 6,000 page report only 500
pages of which were cleared but 500
pages were published and if you read
those as I did there was a section on
couriers and it's described how the why
how they see how I was trying to track
couriers and got nowhere
couldn't do it just couldn't make any
sense of the courier's the names that we
have so many problems with an E and an A
in the name you know how they spelled
differently and
the West some of the Muslim names and we
it's literally said impossible to track
but that's okay according to this CIA to
the debrief not so much in the initial
statements on the day or two later
seeing his senior intelligence officials
even the head of the CIA mr. Brennan he
was then I guess then the White House
was a counter Terry I'm honored the
deputy for counterterrorism Brennan John
Brennan later went to the CI gave
briefings in which they talked about how
we tracked up by couriers and all got
into this torture business gates had
fought bitterly against this saying
don't start lying about torture because
the CIA is worried about the fact that
maybe congressional hearings and there
may be legal findings about what we did
they the CIA was killing people in
torture that happened very much more
than anybody knows there's a lot of
murder going on I wasn't murder they
torture people and they they bled to
death whatever and in some cases that
were murders and no prosecutions of
course in our bure grave there was a
couple of cases where nobody got
punished for anything and so you had
that issue you you were trying to
justify using the couriers and the
problem was that in order for him to be
using couriers you had a goal you had a
contradict the earlier stories about
this guy was isolated at one point they
talked about him sitting around watching
video porno
he was briefed sit they showed a picture
of this old man hunched over watching
pornography it was said you could say
anything you wanted in the first few
days everything was down was taken so
that element the courier's was and the
the people doing the courier tracking
were told my god you helped us you
helped us find him yes it was your work
why not because you want them to think
so because then reporters could talk to
them and the people giving him the
briefings would be convinced they had
you don't tell them about a walk and you
tell nobody about a walker that's a
sacrosanct secret not even inside the
agency so that's one element the other
element is Bohdan had written a piece on
one of the what they call a tick-tock
piece you know five months later he saw
everybody the president and all those
people Brennan and everybody about oh my
god what a wonderful opera he wrote a
piece about the operation
for Vanity Fair a long piece and into
the included account of the photographs
of bin Laden being buried at sea off a
carrier and he described the vividly and
so I knew mark and I like marked anyone
embarrass him I waited till a week
before the piece was published first of
all I knew a lot I knew that where the
bin Laden was taken to is a base in
Pakistan called Jalalabad so a forward
base close to the Hindu Kush mountains
at that time there were no fixed-wing
airplanes there they only used choppers
the aircraft carrier they went to is
something like 800 miles away in the
Indian sea how do you get him there was
a problem secondly I knew from ways I
don't want to talk about because I don't
want to get some Navy officers it
embarrassed but I knew that that
everything is reported on a navy ship
and that night the Navy that aircraft
carrier never turned around to recover
anybody never told higher command we're
picking up a chopper now or an airplane
that's very important they have to do
that there was no such report in the in
the in the logs and the logs have since
been classified the third thing is I
didn't know they were Imams aboard an
aircraft carrier ready to do it official
a Muslim married so I asked I knew that
there was impossible that that [ __ ] that
that happened so I called mark up he's
teaching at the University of Delaware
and and I said to mark mark I'm gonna
ask you a question to which I think the
answer before I ask you is no and here's
the question did you actually see those
photographs you described so vividly in
your article he described how they went
in and how they looked long pause and he
said no I said well how did you learn
about him well I was given a briefing
about him and from somebody I trust that
he described them very vividly I said
well why didn't you say you you didn't
you know why did you say you hadn't seen
him he said well there was something to
the effect I'm something the effect that
he wish he had or the editors didn't
want it there was more vivid if I just
in if I didn't if I left that out and
I'm telling you that's what happened and
so I can understand look he didn't see
him
it didn't happen I'm sorry it just
didn't happen they didn't know what to
do the body was a mess let me tell you
why the body was a mist because the
seals were only supposed to fire a few
shots there was six as I say they come
in groups of six you know in a dingy one
guy guarded the door and and by the way
when they use the plastique to blow up
the steel steel covered doors they had
learned from the ISI in advance exactly
the dimensions and the thickness of the
steel because plastique 64 if you use
too much of it will kill you so I had
just the right mouse and I do wonder one
of the questions is how do they know
just enough to lock the door down with
anybody getting hurt anyway all because
the Pakistanis were giving us that kind
of intelligence there was a lot of
back-and-forth once they decided to play
ball with us to two leaders and so what
they did is they fired a lot of bullets
into him dum-dum bullets and you don't
have to do many but each of the guy took
took some shots and the buzz wasn't much
left of the body we're never gonna see
photographs of the body they produce one
sort of tortured I don't know how they
did a picture of him with two holes in
it but I gotta tell you there were a lot
of holes in the guy's head you could you
know I don't have to tell you how easy
it is to make a photograph
you know depict anything you want
anybody saw that wonderful movie what
was it called the fog of war the a movie
that anyway doesn't matter some movie
with that describes how we faked a war
done back in the Clinton years anyway so
what happened is I mean whacked magnin
don't wag the dog remember how let's get
let have a dog and there's a brook
running and I remember let's change the
color of this I you can do that and so
anyway I don't know why people don't pay
more attention to that stuff but I
looked at yeah go ahead yeah I I found a
quote from Hillary Clinton when she just
became Secretary of State on her first
visit to Pakistan this was in first part
of 2009 and she said this is a quote
from her from on that trip and she said
this in Pakistan I find it hard to
believe that nobody in your government
knows where Osama bin Laden is
now she would not have said that I don't
think in 2009 in Pakistan if she didn't
have some assurance from the
intelligence community that in fact the
Pakistanis did know in 2009 exactly
where he was there she is on record
saying we heard this then after the raid
in 2011 just two years later she said
quote there's absolutely no evidence
that anyone at the highest levels of the
Pakistani government knew so in other
words she went back on what she said
after the raid and I don't want to
introduce politics into this discussion
but what does that say about Secretary
Clinton and you think this is something
she should be asked if she's running for
president oh well it's you know it's not
gonna be asked because it involves too
much you know too much uh you know it's
it's complicated and politics as played
out it's a simple question right she
said this once and then two years later
she said that well then you'd have to
you'd have to be you'd have to somebody
who maybe buys in the questions about
what happened and that's an
uncomfortable thought that the president
you know we had I'll tell you something
more in his initial statement that night
the president when he decided and when
the the political people won out he made
a public statement in which he made a
made a lot of assertions I write a lot
about it I don't know whether he knew
everything he was saying was untrue or
most of it was because you know
president sometimes they get a speech
and they deliver read a speech I don't
know what the men's rear did he know how
much he described bin Laden as having
been confronted with weapons and we got
a treasure trove I remember that of
documents here you are you're on the run
seals on one of my favorite stories that
they keep on talking about all the books
sometimes they say the seals took out
the books with him that night is if they
hadn't time to carry out bags of books
or as if the seals or most of my listen
guys I some of them are I'm sure very
bright but I yeah I can't imagine that
the seals are after you know after
having a chopper crash being in a panic
sitting there looking at the bookcase
saying which one should I take first
which which one do I want to read first
it's comical some of the stuff they did
so you have to buy into that story but
that night the president also said I
want to thank the Pakistani
counterintelligence
forces for their help in and help and
they had to get rid of that within days
they were explicitly saying the
president misspoke and then the next
week he went on television and by this
time within a week I knew the day after
the raid that there was trouble the
gates had made some real problems for
them I didn't know that I didn't know
that from somebody high up in the White
House that Gates was considered to be an
enemy he was against this and then what
people don't want to know about me I
guess is had known I wrote a piece for
the New York New Yorker about the
Pakistani bomb on our fear about it and
I got I spent weeks in Pakistan they've
been there for three or four times
before that and I spent weeks that I
really got into some interesting stuff
to the point where and here's what
happens in the government you do a story
and you you come in with some some
issues that this is Obama administration
some issues that are comfortable and the
White House denies everything that's
just what they do and but so they denied
we had I said there was whatever I said
I said that our goal basically was to
make sure Pakistani could not Pakistan
could not fire a bomb without our
approval and if they ever tried to we
wanted to be in a position to knock out
the whole system the whole system so
they couldn't fire electronically
actually attacked the igloos knock out
the command system it's a pretty tough
thing to say and so after denying all
this the White House called up my editor
Dave Remnick and David called me to say
that he gotten a call from somebody high
in the government and this is - the
night before the story closed must have
been a Thursday night the story it makes
him goes to print Friday night at
midnight somewhere in Tennessee and he
said that they're very concerned and
they said that if the story goes we one
of the things we did at The New Yorker
and we do what the London Review is we
do share what we're writing with the
with the people give him a chance to
talk even though it's usually hopeless
and they said David said that that the
the American government somebody senior
in the government that he respected I
guess anew maybe just because of the
position had told him that if the
story's published as it was we would
have to close our embassy immediately
and our consulates we have a bunch of
consulates the big country and move the
people out for fear riots because the
fundamentalists who really love the bomb
would attack us for for alleging we had
so we tone down the story quite a bit
quite a bit so I have contacts I say
that to mention that I have contacts in
Pakistan and within it I heard the day
after that there was problems in River
City inside the White House with with
with Bob gates
he was seen as somebody who wasn't on
the team on this and and I heard then
from somebody close to the intelligence
service in Pakistan a three page email
that described pretty much what I ended
up writing I went to Americans I had a
wait a day or so I went it waited till
the middle of week and I went to some
Americans who would have known
everything about it I have I'm sorry I
have contacts you know Bob Bob a
journalist we all have to depend on
briefings you know and we have to depend
on access if you're covering the White
House you've got to maintain good
relationships and you can't go off the
wagon too much you could be aggressive
but not too far and and the the manna
the thing you want is somebody who in
the government and there are many people
like that a lot of wonderful people our
government whose loyalty and when they
signed the oath of offices to the
Constitution and not to the President
and when you have somebody like that on
the inside who is as appalled by the
line and the misdirection and also
leaving the two senior generals who
control the bomb with the reason they
hate us we left them with two option
Posse and Keanu one option was to tell
everything to the people that we knew he
was there and have their children not be
able to walk to school because of fear
of being counter-attack by by the
fundamentals who are very vigorous there
the other option is do what they did we
screwed up and we didn't know our radio
system a radar system didn't work here's
a radar system that we paid and you can
find it
900 million bucks for all you had to do
with some work if you're a reporter the
next week instead of calling up at
beggin the White House for another
briefing he'll take a look at what's
online the contracts that are left you
can find stuff even the most
top-secret contracts have to be
announced they may be announced
top-secret contracts or so and so for
this no more detail but you can find
that they have to be announced somewhere
in the government and so nobody did that
all you had to do is go do the research
and you would see that the stories about
the raid are not working we left them in
this horrible position they're having to
say to their nation that they're their
national defenses including the
protection against a nuclear attack a
first strike from from the hated Indians
Wow is capable of being so easily
defeated and that was a terrible
position to leave him and engage his
position was all along his underlying
position so I believe is that you're
messing with the two guys that control
the bomb you're undercutting our faith
and confidence their faith and
confidence in us and that's to me the
reason why the real power behind what
I'm writing is and the real issue is
that we have jeopardized the
relationship with you know what we used
to be so frightened of what we call the
Islamic bomb it's there and we've not on
good terms with the Pakistanis so I'm
sorry go ahead so I wanted to shift
gears a little bit in the time we have
left because a large part of your book
obviously several chapters have talked
about Syria and Syria is a I don't know
a five sided Rubik's Cube with very
difficult to see you know through the
Hall of Mirrors there the the United
States is supporting some rebels and not
other rebels and we're supporting Iraq
but Iraq supports the Syrian government
and Iran supports the Iraqi and Syrian
government's and there's you know it's a
it's it's a it's a mess right and you
talked a lot about Syria and the the gas
attack and a number of other things but
one of the points that really struck me
is the chapter you call
military-to-military and you talk about
how the military essentially on its own
initiative the Joint Chiefs undertook to
sabotage or undercut presidential policy
in theory because they didn't agree with
it you say on page 101 we did this
without going through political channels
on page 102 Obama didn't know the next
page you say it was not some sinister
Joint Chiefs plot to go around Obama to
support Assad but a few pages later you
say that Assad understood this message
that were we can stop presidential
policy says the military you say it
doesn't sound like military independent
thinking and action but it does sound
exactly like that and regardless of what
you think about obama's syria policy and
as a reporter i've done my own reporting
on that isn't it kind of scary that the
military as you report undertook to
provide intelligence indirectly to assad
while US official policy was the support
the the overthrow of assad i think this
happened because as i it's a complicated
question you've done a close read on it
and and you're right it isn't
complicated because you say directly
that the military did something
independently without informing the
white house to essentially support i
don't know i don't want to call us at an
enemy but somebody who you know we
didn't like and we're trying to get rid
of the issue was for the military is
very complicated because there was a
tremendous amount of disagreement in
with with the military of the american
policy if you remember one of the
articles I also wrote was called the red
line and the red line it was about the
the shipping of weapons into Turkey
through air codons Turkey air girl and
we now know is of course his it's pretty
well known he's become quite sort of
crazy
he's now there's a just just just in the
last day or so the UN is raising
questions about the murder of PKK the
opposition Kurds that are going on daily
and he's also supported the Isis very
much an illness I where there's no
question we have intelligence on that
and I mean had for years and it was very
hard to get the White House to switch
from the military's point of view the
arms going in we're there whatever
moderates existed in 2012 by early 2013
have pretty much been overtaken by the
crazies by the more fundamental Salafist
some hobbies the group supported by
Saudi Arabia and Qatar most notably and
so meanwhile whistles shipping arms to
the alleged moderates who had lost a lot
of leverage inside and many of them by
the way in the last count
61 various different tribal groups have
made an accommodation with Assad in the
last six or so months he's been making
accommodations with groups have become
disaffected that maybe were rebels but
they were disaffected because the
control of the opposition was in the
hands of people who if they'd taken over
the country would have caused enormous
trouble Israel would have been concerned
about an Isis government you know
because they would have been the next
target
the Iranian certainly would remove so
there was and it was very it was very
difficult for them to get a reading in
the White House the White House was
stuck on a policy and the president was
isolated and my understanding was that
on a lot of issues memos from the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs general
Dempsey would who's now retired would
just disappear into a void and this is
something you hear quite a bit that a
lot of bureaucratic stuff doesn't
doesn't get to the president he's rather
isolated and removed and so yes they did
decide that it was very important for
Bashar to maintain leverage this doesn't
mean that in some future time if an
election process goes on he would be out
of office but at this time he was doing
he was he was getting shaky in 2013 and
we also were very concerned I will tell
you that by the fact and it is a fact I
have documents and it doesn't matter you
know it's it's I I even mentioned a
documents in one story very secret to
stuff I had that by early spring of 2013
we knew that Saudi Arabia and the Turks
were passing a chemicals into
Eleuthera and what became Isis more
radical groups that when melded together
created a form of very powerful nerve
agent very difficult to work with but we
knew they had that capability
they were huge studies done about it in
June July and June May June and July
even in one study about maybe how many
troops would it take to wipe out all of
the chemical weapons and that were in
the opposition's hand it was 60,000
troops it couldn't just too many
American troops we thought about doing
it this is before the August event in
which we claimed Bashar did the did
murdered his own people would with nerve
gas it is and so the issue was we had
the kind of intelligence that he needed
we have satellite intelligence we have
intercepts and the Germans were there
helping him and so we passed it the
Germans asked for help and once they
asked for help we give allies a lot of
help I'm giving you the rationale I'm
not disputing your assessment of what
the import was and what was understood
and I'll tell you something about
Dempsey we always think about generals
asserted neuters Dempsey majored in
English at the academy Military Academy
and the air army which does this often
recognizing his he was quite skilled I
guess as a student they allowed him to
spend two years getting a master's
degree in fine arts at Dukies he's
reknowned
among his friends and peers for his
reading knowledge and for his love of
Yeats that his knowledge about Yeats
he's sort of a passionate devotee and
the day he retie retired he retired
August 31st of last year and September
of the first instead of joining the 14
boards of defense corporations many as
our former chairman do and make you know
five hundred thousand dollars a year and
that and war he went back and he was
given an appointment at Duke and he's
teaching there he's a different cat and
so he made the call I guess with the
help of others inside the Joint Chiefs
and outside the government perhaps to
start helping supplying some of Bashar
Assad the president of packet of of I'm
getting lost here of Syria of Syria with
intelligence that would help him
turn the corners on the war and he did
and the other big thing that happened in
the war that in the last year was course
the one that doesn't sound that doesn't
seem like treason to you to to to
deliberately undercut the president's
policy I mean I you can quit if you're a
general and then you can speak out but
really you kind of pretty much have to
salute and say yes sir if you're in
Joint Chiefs don't you I find it pretty
refreshing that we had a chairman of the
Joint Chiefs who tried to express a view
and in that same article in the next
paragraph I quote the former by name the
head of the former and I mentioned
Dempsey by name too in the article the
Chairman the former head of the the
Defense Intelligence Agency I quote him
by name who we found that Michael T
Flynn Michael Flynn who's um yeah I was
gonna I was gonna ask you about well but
because he um he site him as a source
one of the few people on the record you
know you talk about and you portray him
as kind of a truth teller and somebody
who resisted Obama he was fired as head
of dia a couple years ago but here's the
thing about about Flynn I mean he's
recently emerged as an advisor one of
the top advisors to Donald Trump
absolutely he's written a book he's
written a book with Michael Adeem who is
one of the well they're right they're
writing the book they're writing the
book now well no it's it's a probably
published right and its own yeah it's
called
his title is field a fight how we can
win the global war against radical Islam
and its allies so I mean Flynn has
clearly put himself in the camp of an
extremist on fighting Islam in the
global war against terrorism I don't
know why he was fired from dia but from
the sound of it he was fired because he
was insubordinate he was a he was a
radical who wanted to go after these
guys and he accuses the president of not
wanting to fight hard enough against
Islamism and and all that just the way
you know the the ultra conservatives do
he was very much you know it was let me
let me he that you quote him as a
a truth-teller you know uh because it he
one of the issues was about him a you
know as you as you know he also worked
as the the head of intelligence for this
Joint Special Operations Command for
years he was a two and three star work
and he worked with McChrystal in Iraq
during the write the most brutal of the
time in Iraq when they were just
assassinating people by the hundreds
during the the you know the honor
insurgency effort there in Anbar and and
so on Wow absolutely there was a lot of
stuff going on that was considered to be
wonderful and you know if you notice
McChrystal really got always great press
and he was promoted by Obama after years
in Iraq of Duty being very bloody to be
head of the war in Afghanistan and so on
all of that I and Flynn was always there
he was a very active with the press
corps a lot of people had his email
which is how I got it and the the issue
for me there was you course describe
somebody he was very conservative and
got got pushed out um but the fact of
the matter is what he said was very
consistent with everything I knew and he
was willing to say it on the record and
he what it was is that there was a whole
series of reports that summer about
al-nusra and Isis has it emerged very
early about how dangerous they were and
how they had access to chemical weapons
too and so on that basis I will tell you
that Obama he was shoved out and they
wanted him shoved out earlier but he you
know when you get a source on the record
and he's saying something that you know
from documents you have that is also so
and if you'd make it a point to make
sure he was somebody who was held you
know he was considered I would say a
wild band but if you go back and look
heaping evening he's been quoted by so
many journalists along the way all the
way and so he wasn't necessarily in this
case somebody on the record who was
saying something that suited my what I
learned is that he was that he and the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs there's
that
we're Sympatico on this issue there are
many issues they were not simpatico on
you know he he was certainly his real
problem was he created also dissent
internally he was reorganizing things
her pregnant was like cold he was
reorganizing things on the inside but I
don't think I think in all fairness to
the guy I think he was calling it as he
saw it yes in that case he was
absolutely right and I had documents
that demonstrated they actually came
from his office and went to his office
some of the stuff all source stuff CIA
NSA Israeli intelligence some of the
docs some of the reports that were going
on about the amount of amount of nerve
agent potential in the opposition before
the what happened in August before
there's the incident with them in in the
suburb of Damascus when 1,400 people
were killed not that many but that
somebody was alleged to be were alleged
to be killed so you know it's a tough go
somebody on the record and he's what
he's saying is consistent with believe
me I'm checking what he says consistent
with other people involved in terms of
that narrow issue his personal political
views were way off the chart but on the
issue of what he was seeing and what
they were saying he was very consistent
and so the argument against him is he
was mouthy and he was a very
conservative guy and he was always
saying things but if you go back and
look he was used as an authority by all
the major media when he was working for
JSOC you know despite the fact he was
known to be sort of a hard-on right-wing
sort of guy like many officers are and
so there we are you know he live and die
I I don't want to call I don't want to
talk about it as treason I think it was
about an inability to get the White
House to recognize something that had
been reported and reported and reported
which is the moderates don't really
exist this was being reported
consistently by all sources inside and
they weren't paying attention to it so I
think at that point the the the the the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs made a call
that that you know that makes some sense
to me
you know the and your argument that if
you the chairman of the Joint Chiefs is
always beholden to the White House again
that that it's he's beholden the
constitution is what I'm saying and
that's what he saw he saw that the over
of the White House simply was not paying
attention and Obama for better or worse
in the throughout the bureaucracy
there's the one complaint is you really
have a hard time getting stuff to him
and I could tell you well of course not
to not too many generals are
constitutional lawyers and so that's
really what I was getting at when I
asked the question about I don't know if
generals know what the Constitution says
or means but it's certainly not their
job to to interpret it but we've got to
wrap up here it looks like let me ask
you you mentioned at the in your intro
of your book about Obama's legacy at
least on foreign policy I I would say I
guess it kind of starts with the Iran
deal maybe and you know he pledged to
end the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan and
I don't know maybe he tried his best he
he tried to avoid getting entangled in
Syria when Clinton and Kerry were
pushing for a you know much greater
escalation of that fight on the other
hand you know he's got this drone
program I mean how do you where do you
come down on on his legacy when it comes
to foreign policy uh I'm you know I
don't like the fact that he even in the
case of Iran we just had an article by
one of his aides Ben Rhodes in The New
York Times of last Sunday in which he
was bragging about how they manipulated
the press on the Iranian deal did think
it's wonderful what he did in Iran but
the critical thing wasn't about
sanctions and pressures it was about the
fact that after 12 or 13 years of
consistently telling the Iranians that
we will discuss a nuclear deal with you
and enrichment when you stop all
enrichment that was the requirement you
stopped about two or three years ago we
made it known to rouhani and others you
can keep on enriching and that's when
the deal got going and that there's
nothing wrong with saying that there's
nothing wrong with saying in the case of
the sarin deal when when we still
accused Bashar
Assad of doing the sarin and when the
when the attack took place they knew
they had intelligence galore that there
were two suspects elusive pratab
potentially they had sarin and Isis and
also Bashar Assad's military they only
had one suspect they didn't tell the
American people there was another
suspect and they also didn't tell him
that both Dempsey the Chairman of the
Joint Chiefs and general clapper who was
head of the director of overall Intel
National Director of National
Intelligence the overriding agency for
all intelligence services had both told
the president that they couldn't be sure
that they had a case against Bashar they
both said as clapper said it's not a
slam dunk because the sarin that we've
we've seen doesn't match what we know to
be in the arsenal and he doesn't tell
the president the world that and so I
don't I don't like not telling the truth
about critical issues to leave the world
thinking Bashar may have done what he
may not have done and I'm not saying I
know I just say that the whole story has
not been told by the White House is is
like a blood libel to me and that you
know they look you can't get two votes
for Bashar Assad in the in the in the in
the Congress today
I mean he's hated and he's a Hitler and
we love our Hitler's we've had means of
Hitler's you know and I'll take a second
and say this to you he's fighting a life
and death war with those people if Isis
are one of those people get in power he
and his wife and their two beautiful
children are gonna be hung up like
Mussolini you know with their throats
cut you know in the square and yes he
uses barrel bombs but I know what
country that you know heinous I know a
country that used barrel bombs for seven
years in a war in which there are
national security their national
security was not at stake it was us we
use barrel bombs full of Kaka Dilek acid
a defoliant that also has consequences
for all sorts of people as we know now
the number of deford deformities in
Vietnam we use it with a de Paume seven
years reach out barrel bombs why because
they're cheaper a barrel bomb is comes
oil comes in a barrel bomb is 63 gallons
and it's cheaper cheaper than then
dropping a 500 pounder so I always
wonder when we attacked him for that
first we did it I mean I always wonder
about our morality of that and secondly
is it really better if he'd used the
500-pound bomb
which had maybe three times as much
lethal stuff that a barrel bomb III you
know I'm just a I'm not making a case
for the guy he's a despot he's like is
he any worse than the guys in Saudi
Arabia who are chopping off heads right
now among the Shiites in eastern Saudi
Arabia is any worse than Bahrain any
worse than UAE where all sorts of
horrible things are happening to the
Shia and minorities I don't think so
I think he's of a peace and so there we
are I and you asked about the president
not getting involved in Syria he just
put 250 Special Forces troop in this
area and as far as I know Bashar Assad
is the reigning still recognized by the
UN as the reigning power and the in
Russians are there yes with with
approval by the sub oh by the the Syrian
government the Iranians are there with
approval by the Syrian government
Hezbollah the Shia group from from
Lebanon Nasser alders group they're
there with approval by the Syrian
government we're not we're in they're
not with the approval would the
president have put 250 Special Forces
guys into Israel without that casually
or to Canada and hell no so there's I
mean it's a point of view the world sees
what he does and I'll tell you something
else if you think the number of American
troops into Iraq is three or four
thousand as they announced I'm telling
you it's four or five times that amount
and maybe even more if you count the
pilots and crew that are doing the
bombing from the from the ocean and so I
think I think we have to I'm just saying
he's not telling the truth to the people
about some basic stuff and that's bad on
the other hand let me just say this I'd
also think he's probably gonna be the
brightest president were gonna have for
the next 50 years well that is a low bar
but thanks so much for you